limousines ski pour celui son tour du
monde en distance yale des parlements
internationaux après ces prises de
parole devant les élus américains
israéliens britanniques italiens et
japonais ce matin le président ukrainien
s'apprêtent à parler aux français cet
après midi rendez vous a été donné aux
élus à l'assemblée nationale française à
15 heures dans moins d'une heure et demi
maintenant trouve sur place notre envoyé
spécial alexandra renard alexandra
bonjour c'est une prise de parole
attendu prises de paroles inédites un
aussi
effectivement il va s'exprimer
simultanément devant le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale tous nous nous
trouvons c'est un discours qui devrait
durer une quinzaine de minutes on attend
à ce que ce soit un peu comme ça l'est
d'habitude vous l'avez besoin d'aller
parler cette tournée des capitales qu'il
est en train de faire actuellement il
s'est exprimé devant de nombreux
parlements et aujourd'hui donc c'est
devant le parlement français qu'il a
décidé de s'exprimer il sera sans doute
me semblait dans son habituelle tenue
militaire derrière son bureau un peu
spartiate qui étendait d'un petit
drapeau ukrainien depuis le palais
présidentiel où il prendra donc la
parole et c'est moi vous le savez sont
choisis particulièrement en fonction de
son auditoire ils sont souvent très
forts l'objectif c'est d'obtenir la
caution et l'appui du plus grand nombre
c'est de susciter de déclencher des
opinions et des émotions
particulièrement forte pour agir sur
l'esprit à des dirigeants de cette
planète est régulièrement il fait appel
avec à des discours historique des
références historiques pour susciter
l'émotion il est fort possible pour ce
qui est de la france qu'il fasse appel
aux attentats notamment de 2015 ou
peut-être aussi à la résistance des
français face au nazisme en tout cas son
message principal auprès des députés
aujourd'hui eh bien il est clair ces
deux plaidé pour l'intégration de son
pays au sein de l'union européenne mais
également de demander à l'union
européenne d'appliquer de plus forte
sanction envers la russie mais aussi de
continuer à rester en avant-garde pour
ce qui est des efforts diplomatiques
notamment d'emmanuel macron le chef du
cabinet l'ukrainien a pris la parole dès
ce matin et c'est ce matin il a demandé
à obtenir rapidement des armes
offensives qu'il qualifie d' arme de
dissuasion de grands moyens de
dissuasion à l'égard de la russie la
france alexandra qui assure la
présidence tournante de l'union
européenne et où le contexte politique
reste évidemment très marqué cette
guerre s'est imposé comme l'un des
sujets de la campagne présidentielle
effectivement à cette actualité
internationale et vient percuter cette
campagne présidentielle néanmoins tous
les députés candidats devraient être
présents aujourd'hui sauf fabien roussel
il s'est fait porte est absent il a
annoncé sur les réseaux sociaux qu'il
avait des impératifs familiaux il est en
train de vivre un décès le décès de son
beau père et donc préfère rester auprès
de sa compagne marine le pen qui elle
avait demandé avait fait savoir du moins
qu'elle ne participerait pas à la fête à
se lever à 7 bisous conférence devant
l'assemblée nationale finalement elle
s'est ravisée face aux critiques
particulièrement forte elle l'avait fait
savoir qu'elle n'aime pas d'admiration
particulière pour le président ukrainien
que ce que faisait volodymyr zelensky et
bien c'est ce que devait faire tout chef
d'état tous les autres députés candidats
devraient eux être présent à richard
ferrand a pris la parole ce matin
également sur un média français sur une
radio française il a fait savoir qu'il
n'était pas question pour la france
d'imposer un embargo sur le pétrole et
sur le gazon russe jusqu'ici pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de moyen de
substitution at il fait savoir il a
également ajouté les sanctions certes a
infléchi a le pouvoir politique aux
russes pas punir les français et les
autres européens washington a choisi à
son tour de limiter d'interdire pardon
les ses importations de pétrole et de
gaz russe et pour ce qui est du royaume
uni ça devrait être la même chose pour
ces énergies aux russes ils les
interdirons d'ici la fin 2022